i did not believe this headline when i
first saw it i
assumed that this was a sensationalist
headline and that the story would
actually be
a little more anodyne than than the
headline would make it out to be
but actually it's the opposite the the
story just gets worse and worse and
worse the more you read it headline in
the washing or in
the new york post rather gay polly
thrupple makes history lists
three dads on the birth certificate a
gay polyamorous california thruple
i'd have to say the only part of this
story that i don't hate is the word
throuple because it's kind of funny
the reality not so funny but the word
it's funny to say throuple
a gay polyamorous california throuple
made history in 2017
when they became the first family in the
state to list
three parents on a birth certificate
their reproductive journey and legal
battle to become fathers to piper now
three is detailed in three dads and a
baby
out march 9th written by one of her dads
dr ian jenkins these three perverts
names are ian jenkins
jeremy hodges and dr alan mayfield
doctors so they're all look they're very
elite people they're
they're experts there there's no reason
to question their
degenerate behavior they don't see their
family which now also includes their son
parker as unusual
look it's not a big deal okay and then
they go on and explain
why this kind of child abuse is not a
big deal
love is love right love is love love is
love by the logic
of love is love
this makes some sense i i said this at
the time when people were talking about
redefining marriage and they were trying
to turn it
from a basic question about the nature
of marriage
to a question about civil rights and
what you hate gay people and what you're
a mean old
guy or something i said by the logic
that is being pushed here there is no
limiting principle
scalia made this point too i mean the
conservatives at the the actual
conservatives at the time
of the obergefell decision made this
point they say this has nothing to do
with animus for anybody
because of sexual desires or anything
like that we're simply asking
what is marriage if marriage has gone
from being
a natural union of husbands and wives
for the
for the sort of t loss of family
creation
procreation uh the basic political
institution if it if it
goes from that and then you take away
the entire
tea loss the entire purpose of that the
the entire
uh historical understanding of marriage
and the natural purpose of it
and it just means love is love then
there's no reason that it should only
include two people
forget the even the question of men or
women it
there's no limiting you could have 10
people in a marriage if it's all just
about love is love and look they
love having a baby so what are you going
to limit that
what are you selfish this also shows the
question
to be a complete completely ridiculous
argument when sometimes
you'll hear mostly libertarians but
sometimes conservatives will say this
they'll say
look i don't want the government
involved in marriage anyway the
government is involved in marriage
in part not least of all to prevent this
kind of child abuse
but the government failed to prevent
that kind of child abuse sure
because conservatives and libertarians
basically pulled away from the entire
debate and said
we don't want to use the government we
don't want to use our political power we
don't think that
we should stop the left from running
roughshod over our culture anyway so
we've just handed the reins of power
over to the left
we shouldn't be surprised when they
abuse that power but the state obviously
has a role in this if the family is the
basic
political institution then obviously any
political organization from the local to
the national level
is going to have some interest in that
institution
this is the most
selfish thing i have seen
maybe ever certainly the most selfish
big news story i've seen ever
some people are saying michael you don't
know if the child is going to be abused
you don't i'm not saying that the
the guys are all like the marquis de
sade and they're all going to start
doing all sorts of heinous things to the
baby
i'm saying this is the abuse this
the whole thing is the abuse
initially what what it seemed like these
three people were going to do
these three men was that they were going
to adopt
a fertilized embryo so a little
little miniature baby that are that was
frozen through various other
bioethically not totally sound
reproductive practices
and so they were going to adopt it
implanted into a surrogate rent some
woman's womb
have the baby grow and then uh that
would be the baby
and that would that would be bad enough
but it actually is a bioethically
different question because the embryo
already existed the baby was already
created and then thrown in a freezer
like happens
all too often today but then that didn't
work
according to this story the they tried
that a few times and the
babies died basically the little tiny
embryos died and so
what they did was their quote a friend
named megan came to the rescue and
donated her eggs to the trio
so what these guys did was they went out
and they created a baby
for the express purpose of
denying that child the ability to know
her mother ever and then
to be raised in a perpetual orgy
that's what they love is love right
this is the real tiger i don't mention
it only because
i think this should be illegal and these
men should be in prison in a just
society obviously not in our society but
in a just society that would be the case
but that's not the only reason i mention
it the reason i mention it has a broader
cultural and political point
this is tiger king what the
dominant liberal elite wants us to
believe is that
tiger king you know the the kind of the
the kind of crazy behavior and the
sexual
bizarre arrangements and all this kind
of selfishness
that that happens on a on a tiger farm
in florida you know it's florida man
it's the got
joe exotic with the mullet and he talks
funny and he smokes a lot of meth or
whatever and he's in a
he's in this exact relationship he's in
this sort of gay thrupple
uh no the real tiger king
culture happens with our elites
these guys are these are medical doctors
right i think so maybe they're just
using the term doctor
a little more broadly than that but
you've got two doctors these guys have
advanced education they seem to be
fairly well off because these processes
are pretty expensive
they are engaging in in far more
egregious behavior than any florida man
like joe exotic ever did the depravity
of our culture
does not come from the deplorable
irredeemable bitter clinging people in
the middle of the country who voted for
that fascist trump
the depravity far greater depravity
comes from the liberal elite
that pretends to be so much better than
us that tells us how to live
our lives think of the children as an
overused line and it is often exploited
by demagogues so i try to avoid the line
you know i don't want to sound like the
lady in the simpsons well somebody
please think of the children
however there are some circumstances
where you actually
need to think of the children think of
what a selfish monster you have to be
to do this to a baby i mean i'm saying
i'm now seeing a baby like
quite a lot and the baby's keeping me up
quite a lot
a baby has an a right
to his parents sometimes you know
obviously kids are in bad circumstances
and
kids can be adopted in certain ways
let's not forget of course that there
are
something like 32 couples trying to
adopt for every baby up for adoption in
the united states
but this is a totally different to
create a baby
to deny the baby his mother to put them
to put these babies into this bizarre
selfish sexual situation absolutely
outrageous tommy tuberville
new republican senator made this point
on the senate floor he said you know
there there are times in this country
even if the line is overused
when you do have to think of the
children we've got to start teaching our
young people
moral values again that starts with
putting god and prayer back in our
schools
our kids need structure and they need to
learn right from wrong
i've watched everything that has
happened in education over the past few
decades
from a front row seat on my sideline as
a coach
it's embarrassing as a person who
chooses to spend their career in
education
i now have the opportunity to say
something as a united states senator
our young people are our number one hope
for this country's future
if we don't recognize that we're going
to lose our country
as we know it so what what tommy
tuberville is saying here it's not
some emotionally manipulative play he's
just he's stating a truism right the
children
the children are the future in as much
as
we're born we grow we die
and then the next generation rinses and
repeats right so
when you look i've been saying this for
years when you look at a university
campus
it's not like that's some little zoo and
then the kids are going to get fixed
when they get into the real world
you're looking at the future you're
looking at a crystal ball for your
country
so if children are educated to
exercise their moral conscience practice
the virtues learn their nation's history
love their country and develop their
faculties of higher
learning their higher reason that
is going to lead to one kind of a
country a good country if
on the other hand kids are not taught
even
sort of the rudimentary things that will
help develop their faculties of reason
and they're also taught a bunch of
cockamamie left-wing theories about how
terrible
their country is and about how awful
conservatives are or something and
how awful the founding fathers are if
they're taught that they can't even
discern right and wrong
that you can't trust your moral
conscience if you're taught that
you can't make judgments from the
natural world you can't make ethical
judgments
then you're gonna have a different kind
of country you're gonna have tiger king
country which these three
perverts are showing us pretty clearly i
hope you enjoyed that clip from the
michael knowles show to check out the
full episode
hit the link in the description or
download the michael knowles show
wherever you listen to podcasts